le masculin ne l'emportent pas sur le
féminin c'est l'avis des promoteurs de
cette écriture dit inclusive écriture
qui viserait à rétablir la parité entre
les hommes et les femmes dans la langue
française si les noms et les adjectifs
sont systématiquement écrit au masculin
et au féminin on va en voir un exemple à
l'écran avec ce point médian dont on va
parler
une question pour vous tous si une
marotte délirantes ou c dans l'air du
temps soit moi j'avais envie de vous
dire que oui vous ne m'aviez fait venir
en tant que femme pour défendre
féministes ou chez pac quoi cette
histoire s'est c'est tragique mais en
plus c'est tout ça et développer il faut
rappeler dans un manuel pour les élèves
de ce2 j'ai envie de dire mais qu'on
laisse nos enfants tranquilles quoi
l'orthographe est déjà suffisamment
complexe pour qu'on ne vienne pas leur
alors se sentir ligne michel est en
train de vous couper l'herbe sous le
pied à tous je vais commencer le débat
la langue française n'est pas une langue
neutre
contrairement à l'anglais oui la réponse
est oui
est-ce qu'elle marque est ce qu'elle
exprime le caractère dominant masculin
de notre société oui est ce qu'il
faudrait est ce que les femmes devrait
revendiquer des choses pour leurs
conditions oui absolument il est un
scandale qu'au xxième siècle les femmes
continuent à être dévalorisé payer moins
que les hommes et c est ce que le sujet
est très important oui chaque jour on a
des ddd exemple dans notre vie que la
place des femmes net est très loin
d'être légalité de celle des os x c'est
ma grande avancée mais c'est pas le lieu
c'est pas le lieu est alors qu'on me
démontre que le point inclusif qui n'est
même pas qu'on ne peut même pas exprimer
à l'oral
ce qui me gêne c'est d'y enfin les bleus